Laurene if folks and the audience aren't
familiar with this this is in fact based
on a magazine article that appeared in
New York magazines the cut I love it if
you could take me to back to that moment
the first time you read that article and
what it was that really stuck out to you
that made you go on to think this Canon
should be a movie it was sent to me by
Jessica album so thank you
Jessica um in the summer of 2016 which
was a different time on planet Earth
and I was really taken with the themes
that it talked about gender as it
relates to the economy capitalism I
thought it was a really incredible look
at a world that we don't often get to
see at least not from the dancers
perspective and I thought there was a
really compelling friendship story at
the root of it so I was just really
taken with the story the the process of
the reporting itself the journalist and
and the characters involved and yeah the
themes that it touched upon it was just
felt really urgent and organic yeah and
and Jennifer there are so many different
themes in this film which was the one
that was kind of the the most compelling
one for you that really brought you into
this project themes I would say probably
the difference between the way women are
treated and men are treated for the same
exact thing was something that you know
I mean they're both in essence stealing
and the guys all get off and the women
go you know go to get arrested
but but there was many things about it
obviously about the script that I loved
you know just it reminded me a little
bit of like Goodfellas or Boogie Nights
in the sense that the minute I read it
that it was like this dangerous kind of
sexy kind of glamorous world but that
was really scary and that people don't
really get to go into the day-to-day of
all the time from the people who are in
it so if you think about the Mafia the
porn industry or the strip club it has
to be told from the woman's point of
view and had never those type of movies
are
ever told from the woman's point of view
so to me that was really really
interesting as well and just to kind of
lay maybe you can talk a little bit
about what it took to actually get this
film made and made rather swiftly
especially considering some of the
themes going on say we're gonna make a
film about a bunch of strippers conning
a bunch of Wall Street guys how'd that
go over wasn't wasn't easy we had a lot
of people throw us out tell us no and
you know it took a minute to find the
right home and it was Sisyphus yeah I
mean it was not easy as an
understatement I aspired for it to not
be easy it was it was probably the
hardest thing I've ever experienced
because it was beautifully written
beautifully constructed
we had Jennifer Lopez in a role she
understood it was a complex interesting
sexy empowering messed-up character and
we had a real that Lorene had cut
together from our brilliant editor Kayla
that was insanely great and we put this
movie on our backs and we went
everywhere because Annapurna kept
getting us to the starting gate and then
not pulling the trigger and we went
everywhere we went to streamers we went
everywhere and everyone could recognize
the pedigree certainly of Lorene and and
certainly of Jennifer and they wanted to
be in business and they loved the idea
that it was a stripper movie as they
said it was like a scene out of the
player but why can't the strippers why
can't the guys who they drugged rape
somebody like if they could just be
really bad guys then great will make
that movie and you know we said it's
based on a true story so you know we
can't change the the fact of it and part
of the brilliance of Loreen SCAF areas
writing is that she doesn't judge her
character she allows them to be as
complex and interesting and twisted and
you know [ __ ] up as as some many
people are and they wanted us to
demonize the men to justify the women
because
they said we just are absolutely certain
that the audience at home won't want to
see women taking advantage of men and I
guess I guess they're wrong
Jennifer you're dancing and this was
extraordinary and I think one of the
things thank you and and I just want to
say having once as a reporter taking a
pole dancing class
just take one dance class and when you
make it look that easy I mean that's
really can you talk about just about the
physical experience of it because I
think yes it's it's made to look easy
but it is not no it's extremely
difficult than when you know I took on
the movie and I loved the character and
I was like okay she has to have this
great dance in here because she is the
girl at the club she's the one who's got
it all figure out and she's the best and
she has to have that moment and I
thought okay great I'll take some pole
dancing classes this will be so sexy
okay so fun oh my god then I was like oh
my god this is the hardest thing I've
ever done this hurts so bad that steel
pipe in my legs and it was hurting and
you got to hold on with your stuff and
it's like it was so hard and remember
the first day I went into my bowl class
I'm like in there with my sweat pants
and my switch and I'm like okay show me
out of all dance and she's like well
okay it'll be better if you're in your
bra and panties and I was like excuse me
she was like yeah you know the skin is
what sticks and you will slip off and
crack your head open if you do it with
your sweatpants on I was like okay shows
might as well get used to it now that's
okay
I guess you're right all right myself
but it was incredibly incredibly hard
probably one of the hardest thing didn't
just be people are like oh you're a
dancer must have been somewhat easy but
no it's actually like learning
acrobatics it's a whole different thing
and I just knew that if I could because
Ramona was who she was in the club and
and and was the best kind of stripper
dancer at the club that I had to pull
off at least three minutes of this or
whatever it was
this length of this song and so I just
learned that we worked on the moves
first the acrobatics upside down and
then I said luring make sure you get my
face so they know it's me I don't care
if I look crazy I don't care if I look
like a bat just get my face once we
learned all of those very intricate
spins and moves and climbs and things
and then I started adding in the other
layer of the stripper and the siren and
the person who's drawing them in and the
person who understands how to work the
crowd and get the money and make them
laugh and make them think many many
different things while she's up there
it's interesting of the films that
you've referenced none of them are
sports films which is kind of how you
wound up treating and if we could just
talk about the filmmaking itself yeah
for a moment particularly that scene and
how you approached it as really more of
an athletic endeavor then yeah yeah I
mean a Todd man hazel and I DP we spoke
a lot about this theme of control that
runs through the film and we wanted to
apply that to the visual language as
well and so a scene like that is where
we're seeing Ramona in control of
everything including the camera Ramona
is in total control of where the camera
go is the moment we cut the moment we
cut back and so yeah of course we wanted
to see Destiny's point of view destiny
seeing Ramona for the first time but
really highlight the athleticism of it
the strength the power that it takes and
and yeah and that and that sense of
control that remotely also talked about
it being like a stunt yeah because it is
so difficult to do it's not something
you can shoot for a day or two there's
just no way and even the the kind of
half a day or whatever we did maybe 3/4
of a day that it took to shoot maybe a
half a day the first half of the day
before lunch that we shot the scene I
still pulled my shoulder from doing it
so many like ok I'm done and I told her
I said you know we have to
I don't know how many times I'll be able
to do it the whole entire thing through
and she was like we'll shoot it like a
stunt put the you know all the guys so
we you just gotta have like multiple
cameras going at once and try to get in
so that we approached it in that way she
made this movie in 29 days
Laurene SCAF area is a warrior I mean
and this is Jennifer Lopez as is our
second ad our production designer so she
had to know exactly what we didn't have
time we shot that pole scene
at the end the second the last day we
had the last four days and it was all
due to cardio and Liz's schedule and all
of these other factors that come in and
the strip club availability so we had to
back load all of that and I remember we
got up in front of the 250 extra 300 300
dressed in period garb and you know I
remember I stood up there because I
thought the first ad said do you want to
say something to them because Jen was
about to come out and then Cardian uh
sure cuz we shot all that on the same
day and I said you know you guys we've
invited you into this world we're doing
this so quickly
we have no time to redo it please put
your cell phones away they didn't have
those kind of cellphones in 2007 and
you've got to be a part of this and
you've got to protect us and protect the
people because these are really famous
people who are gonna come out and and be
someone else and I remember going up
stage with you we upstairs right and we
sat there and Jennifer does she comes
out well first I came out and you walked
she came and got me at the trailer
they're like they're ready for you and I
prepared for this the whole entire shoot
and I'm ready and I'm like yeah I feel
good I got my dental floss on I'm gonna
walk out and I'm absolutely terrified
and I don't think I've felt that way in
a long time been performing a long time
I took concerts I do all that you guys
know
and they've done tons of movies and I
just and I was really scared for the
first time in a long time at night look
at Elaine who's known me for 25 years
now and we've been working together that
long and she said to me I said uh I'm
nervous I'm scared and she goes what I'm
nervous and she goes yeah you got this
you got this
what's to be nervous about yeah no first
she session what were you are she she
said you are and I said yes I am um I
was I had never I'm still Jennifer but I
was Ramona the whole time and it just
got really real in that moment who
Ramona was for me and what I had to do
and what I was doing it so far from Who
I am that it was just scary it was scary
to go up there all of a sudden there's
300 men there and I have to get up on
this stage you know not not like I do in
my concerts with tights and sparkly
things on and on hey coz I wear sexy
costumes it's not it's not about that it
was different it was a bearing of not
just yourself physically but emotionally
as well and it was just terrifying and I
was like okay and my heart's beating out
of my chest and she's she's like you got
this I said yep yep I got this and it's
just about muscling up and getting up
there and doing your job my thanks to
the for very real people on this stage